I'm Ali I'm Lexy Rosa Kaplan twins and
today we're gonna be not identical for
the day an identical twin it's like
having a built-in best friend yeah we do
ever go together
we're artists so we paint together right
we spend all day together we paint on
the same canvas together I don't think
we're ever really a poor never apart we
actually didn't even realize that we
were identical until like two years ago
yeah yeah it doesn't really work that
way like if you look alike it's more
about like the science behind it I was
told dive for Iran xx 2% is 2m e onyx
this is coming from my neighbor's
fertility doctor what am I supposed to
think but of course the idiot told me
that I can't drink wine grab my little
pregnancy got like the whole DNA test
99.9% Cindy night when you thought we
were fraternal my hair who driver yeah
we tried to be like tips we realize
we're identical we've been like look
more alike we definitely like looking
the same and also it's just easier when
we get dressed in the morning or like we
have somewhere to go she'll put on an
outfit I'll be like oh that looks great
and I'm gonna do the same thing I don't
think this will make us wish we look
different
oh wow I look like I should be taller
like I'm like wearing like a leopard
coat with a martini and like smoking a
cigarette when we meet strangers on the
street there was like oh you guys talk
the same time we talk over you and
especially when we look exactly alike
your life wins it's fun yeah we love it
now that we look different right we're
gonna talk to some people and see if
they react not really if I saw them on
the street I would think that that's a
mother and a daughter it might be more
strange for us or I don't know if we're
talking at the same time just free maybe
I'll be where they'll be like oh these
people are really like in third with
each other I looked at random are they
the Kaplan twins I'm not mad
yeah
our relationship with our mom you're
super clean she's a favorite and then
it's like it doesn't like I'm the
favorite right now I think my mom sees
like my mom sees this just gonna be like
like what like a governor but like a fun
one
[Music]
we're not excited to meet the collector
I don't know maybe she looks like been a
mom so are you gonna look like this when
you're older mental trip I feel like it
must have been I don't know it was just
kind of like like some woman for funny
sigh moments are really weird fusing
yeah yeah so like a lot of emotions yeah
funny
it was that wheat-ricks a couple of
people I think we got away with yeah
yeah I just don't know what to say I
think we want to look the same it just
feels weird feels though yeah the whole
thing feels weird time to be honest all
unit over Oh mr. face yep miss my face
on your face finally were identical
again oh my god I forgot we look I
forgot what I look like I am so happy
I'm so happy for you
right yeah it was fun though you know
but I'm back
[Music]